all right i have a few things today to
catch you up on first and foremost we
have been waiting to see what happens in
georgia with the subpoenas of republican
senator lindsey graham and trump's
former lawyer rudy giuliani with rudy
giuliani his lawyer recently told the
judge in new york he is not fit to
travel for medical reasons he can't fly
down to which the judge said there's
other ways to get down to atlanta you
could take an uber you could take a car
there's other ways to get down there you
could take a train
that is pending with rudy giuliani
however yesterday
lindsey graham or wednesday rather
lindsey graham was supposed to show up
at a courthouse in fulton county and he
did not 46 news from atlanta reporting
senator lindsey graham a no-show at
scheduled fulton county court appearance
this is what we know right now lindsey
graham didn't show up
he was subpoenaed to testify in a
special grand jury investigation looking
at whether trump and others broke laws
when they tried to overturn the results
of joe biden's win in georgia in 2020
lindsay's one of the people trump allies
that the district attorney fannie willis
wants to question
graham said previously he would fight
the subpoena his attorneys say the probe
is politically motivated and graham was
indeed ordered to testify on august 2nd
the petition states that the state of
georgia will pay travel expenses and
witness fees
um lindsay didn't show up
now this thing of political motivation
this is another one of their catch-alls
that they're using and hopefully it
won't be allowed to stand the idea what
they want us to hear when they say this
is politically motivated is there's no
empirical or factual basis to even be
doing this when they go
these are politically motivated
investigations they want you to believe
the person doing the investigation is so
blinded by political bias that they are
investigating or prosecuting or doing or
subpoenaing
on the basis of their political beliefs
not on the basis of their responsibility
as law enforcement and prosecution of
course that's absurd
but more importantly these are alleged
political crimes if you try
to
overturn an election
and have the guy who lost given the
electoral votes
that is politically motivated even
though biden won
you're a republican and trump's a
republican and you want trump to be
president it's fundamentally political
and so it really loses its value to say
that the investigation is political well
if you mean that it's not based on fact
we can talk about that but writing it
off as politically
in the political sphere
has no meaning whatsoever when these are
politicians
trying to achieve political wins through
subterfuge and potentially criminality
and that's what's being investigated
they were politically motivated actions
that they took
and this is the same republican
projection that we've been following for
a long time i did something bad that was
politically motivated and then when you
investigate i'll say you were doing this
based on political motivation it's sort
of like democrats are going to commit
fraud
and try to take an election that the
voters don't really want them to win
well actually that's what you're doing
joe biden won and you were trying to
take an election that the voters didn't
actually want you to win and i would
just write it off as as pitiable
except this stuff is really effective
this stuff is affected i mean in the
aftermath of the 2020 election nearly 60
percent of republicans fell for it and
they believed actually donald trump won
we've been talking about how effective
these silly things are in the context of
herschel walker herschel walker's the
speaking of georgia
the senate republican nominee in georgia
facing off against the incumbent senator
rafael warnock
and
herschel walker doesn't want to debate
and i understand why because herschel
walker can't speak
and so
herschel walker is now starting to say
warnock won't debate me
and it's so predictable and it's so
pathetic and it's so absurd
but it works because the trumpists hear
warnock's the one who won't debate
and they will believe it and they will
repeat it and they won't allow it to
dissuade them from voting for a guy
herschel walker in november who quite
literally cannot explain anything he
cannot explain his view on anything he
can't speak
um so sadly
it's
working for the right to say these are
politically motivated investigations
even if it means absolutely nothing
the david pakman shows longest running
sponsor is blinkist the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
each of them down into an explainer you
can read or listen to in 15 minutes
blinkist also condenses episodes of
popular podcasts into 15-minute
explainers i've been using blinkist for
years to supplement the books i read i
love reading i i read all the time
but there's even more books i don't have
time to read and you can often find
those non-fiction books on blinkist and
consume the entire thing in 15 minutes
my favorite new feature on the app is
blinkist connect which lets you share
your blinkist premium account with
someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users i have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to robert greene's the 48 laws of power
the new version robert greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com david
pakman the link is down below